[Music]
kicking off et's Kardashian ketchup Kim
hit the town for a fun girls night out I
want to wear things that make me feel
good about myself
Kim stepped out for dinner at Craigs
restaurant with her gal pals splashing
major cleavage and legs in a sexy
pinstripe dress with a thigh high slit
she's my little twin soul she's such a
free spirit well move over Kim Kylie
Jenner is breaking the internet exposing
her bare butt for her new cheek tease
available at her online store the Kylie
shop I'm having so much fun I feel like
I'm getting into so many cool Beauty
things I'm excited about it meanwhile
Kendall is 20 with her pal Bella Hadid
during Paris Fashion Week the model
Powell stepped out in all red ensembles
and slicked back hair
here's Bella rocking a bright red
low-cut jumpsuit
while 21 year old Kendall sports a
nearly identical look in an oversized
blazer crop top and leather pants and
check out Penelope and Mason Disick
hilariously ranking their famous on the
nicest in front of you that's what you
said pee what about in cocoa and cocoa
are amazing at all this and cocoa is
cocoa is the craziest with the biggest
bud Oh a Coco Loco
she does have the biggest bird